ja
liebe liebe Freundinnen und
Freunde etwas Neues zu beginnen das
Gesicht ganz vorne in den Wind zu halten
das erfordert Mut und ich denke wir
kennen sie alle die Zweifel vor dem
richtigen Weg die Frage wir werden
Freunde Bekannte auf diesen Schritt
reagieren und auch die Sorge ob wir die
riesige Aufgabe die jetzt vor uns steht
ob wir die wirklich bewältigen oder ob
sie uns vielleicht auch überfordert ihr
habt die Entscheidung getroffen deshalb
seid ihr heute hier als
erstmitglieder des Bündnisses Sarah
Wagenknecht dass es ohne euch nicht
geben würde und darüber freue ich mich
und ich danke euch dass ihr den Mut
dafür aufgebracht
habt wir machen uns jetzt
wir machen uns jetzt gemeinsam auf den
Weg die Politik in Deutschland zu
verändern und wir tun das weil wir
spüren da ist etwas am kippen in unserer
Gesellschaft es gibt so viele Probleme
so viel
Unsicherheit aber auch so viel Empörung
und Wut die Politik des Aussitzens und
wegmoderierens der kleinen Kompromisse
und der großen Ignoranz die wird
wahrscheinlich so nicht weitergehen aber
die Frage ist was kommt dann mündet der
Umbruch in einen Aufbruch oder in die
Katastrophe alles ist möglich und wir
starten auch jetzt deshalb weil wir
nicht nur zuschauen sondern weil wir
eingreifen und handeln wollen weil ab
jetzt hängt es auch von uns ab wie
Deutschland in 5 oder 10 Jahren aussehen
wird und ich denke das ist ganz wichtig
und es ist toll dass ihr dabei
seid
liebe liebe Freundinnen und Freunde uns
ein die gemeinsame Sorge um die Zukunft
uns einen die programmatischen Ziele die
in unserem Programm formuliert sind aber
wir sind auch sehr
verschieden viele von uns haben sich
über viele Jahre in der Linken engagiert
andere kommen aus anderen Parteien und
wieder andere haben sich zum ersten Mal
in ihrem Leben entschieden politisch
aktiv zu werden unter uns sind
Gewerkschafter Betriebsräte undter
vololgreiche Unternehmer Krankenpfleger
und Polizisten Theologen und Atheisten
Großstädter und Dorfbewohner in einem
Land das sich immer mehr in Lager
spaltet in dem die einzelnen milies sich
immer seltener begegnen ist das keine
Selbstverständlichkeit sondern etwas
ganz besonderes und wertvoll
und wir werden auch nur erfolgreich sein
wenn wir diese unsere
Unterschiedlichkeit als Gewinn begreifen
wenn wir Toleranz und Respekt nicht nur
in der Gesellschaft einfordern sondern
auch hier in unserer Partei Leben das
muss unser Auftrag und das muss unser
Ziel
sein und Freunde wir sind keine linke 20
und das muss auch für unseren Umgang
miteinander gelten lasst uns eine Partei
des Miteinanders werden und nicht eine
Partei der Intriegen und des
postengeschachers wie alle
anderen und lasst uns Strukturen
schaffen in denen sich nicht die
rücksichtslosesten und intrigantesten
durchsetzen sondern die talentiertesten
und besten denn das wollen wir auch in
der Gesellschaft und dann fangen wir bei
uns an das ist ganz wichtig und das wird
uns von allen anderen unterscheiden wenn
wir so
sind und deshalb bitte ich
euch lasst uns pfleglich miteinander
umgehen ich glaube das ist ganz wichtig
dass wir das zu unserem Credo machen es
ist unsere
Verantwortung die großen Erwartungen die
Hoffnungen die jetzt ganz viele Menschen
auf uns setzen die wir täglich erleben
wenn uns Menschen ansprechen auf der
Straße im
Supermarkt lasst uns diese Hoffnungen
diese Erwartungen nicht enttäuschen das
ist unsere große Verantwortung die wir
alle gemeinsam jetzt tragen müssen und
unser Land es braucht unbedingt einen
politischen Neubeginn für
wirtschaftliche Vernunft statt
Klientelpolitik für soziale gerech
chtigkeit statt einer immer wachsenden
Ungerechtigkeit und Ungleichheit für
Frieden für Entspannung statt neuer
hochristungswettläufe und immer mehr
Krieg und ja auch für Meinungsfreiheit
und Respekt gegenüber dem
Andersdenkenden statt kcel culture und
einem übergriffigen politischen
Autoritarismus den wir in der coronazeit
in seiner krassesten Form erlebt haben
aber der ja heute auch nicht weg ist
sondern der das Meinungsspektrum immer
weiter verengt und das machen wir nicht
mit das wollen wir verändern und es ist
wichtig dass sich das
ändert immer mehr Menschen immer mehr
Menschen in unserem Land sind politisch
heimatlos geworden weil sie statt
vernünftiger Entscheidungen eine Politik
erleben die keinen Plan und keine
Antworten hat eine Politik die sich nur
noch in ihrer Blase bewegt und die
Probleme die die Bürgerinnen und Bürger
in unserem Land jeden Tag erleben die
diese Probleme nicht nur nicht löst
sondern offenkundig zum Teil noch nicht
einmal kennt Amira hat ja das Beispiel
vorhin genannt der V von Ricarda lang
immerhin Vorsitzender einer
Regierungspartei bei der Abschätzung der
deutschen Durchschnittsrente das ist
doch das Sinnbild dieser Abgehobenheit
wie soll jemand eine vernünftige
Rentenpolitik machen der noch nicht
einmal weiß welche Probleme die
Millionen Rentnerinnen und Rentner in
unserem Land überhaupt haben das ist
doch
absurd und vermutlich vermutlich denkt
Robert habbeck auch alle Menschen in
Deutschland leben in modernen
Niedrigenergiehäusern oder in den
schönen topsanierten altbaulofts wie
seine grünen Freunde in den
hochpreisigen großstadtquartieren und
deshalb hielt er das für eine geniale
Idee ganz Deutschland eine Wärmepumpe
für den Heizungskeller zu verordnen so
läuft Politik heute aber genau deswegen
wenden sich eben immer mehr Menschen ab
oder der frühere Blackrock Lobby ist
Friedrich März der im Privatflieger
durch die Welt düst und ernsthaft glaubt
so lebt die deutsche Mittelschicht was
ist daran noch irgendwie bürgernah oder
geerdet das ist doch völlig absurd was
diese Leute
machen
und und vom Höfe sterben hat die ganze
ampelriegel Riege offenbar auch noch nie
irgendwas gehört davon dass allein in
den letzten 10 Jahren
40.000 Landwirtschaftsbetriebe in
Deutschland aufgeben mussten weil sie
dem drppeldruck nicht mehr standhalten
konnten der auf der einen Seite von
mächtigen Supermarktketten und großen
Lebensmittelkonzernen ausgeübt wird und
auf der anderen Seite von billig
Importen die die Politik organisiert hat
und mit immer neuen Freihandelsabkommen
wie mit dem merkosur immer weiter
organisiert offenbar haben die das
überhaupt nicht auf dem Schirm was die
Landwirte in Deutschland für Probleme
haben und deswegen frage ich mich in
welchem Paralleluniversum müssen
Politiker leben die ausgerechnet dieser
Branche jetzt die Stopfen ihrer
Haushaltslöcher auferlegt das ist eine
völlig falsche Politik und wir sagen
ganz klar nein diese Belastungen die
müssen komplett zurückgenommen werden
die Belastungen für die Landwirte die
weil so kann es auf keinen Fall
weitergehen und wenn dann den Bauern
wenn dann den Bauern die Hutschnur
platzt und sie ihren Protest
unüberhörbar auf die Straße tragen ja
dann heißt es plötzlich uh i das ist ja
von rechts über unterwandert weil man
irgendwo neben einem Traktor oder hinter
einem Misthaufen doch im Ernst einen
rechtsradikalen gesichtet hat es ist
tatsächlich das gleiche wie letztes Jahr
Amira hat es schon gesagt als 50.000
Menschen vor dem Brandenburger Tor für
Frieden in der Ukraine demonstriert
haben und von Medien und Politik als
Putin nah aber eben auch als rechtsoffen
und AFD nah defamiert wurden so darf es
doch nicht weitergehen mit den Debatten
in unserem
Land weil
einergebnis ein Ergebnis dieser irren
Debatte ist ja tatsächlich dass die AFD
heute als Friedenspartei gilt eine
Partei die den aktuellen
rekordrüstungsetap von 85 Milliarden
Euro eher noch zu klein findet und deren
verteidigungspolitischer Sprecher das
wissen leider die wenigsten mit der
Rüstungsindustrie wirtschaftlich
verbandelt ist und deswegen um keinen
Deut besser ist als die
rüstungslobbyistin Marie Agnes Strack
reheinmetall das ist doch alles eine
Suppe das ist doch alles völlig
falsch
aber das sind die Diskussionen das sind
die verrückten Diskussionen die wir in
unserem Land teilweise führen das Werben
für Frieden rechts die Verteidigung der
Bauernhöfe rechts die Kritik an
Schulschließungen und Konformitätsdruck
in der coronazeit rechts die Forderung
nach Begrenzung der Zuwanderung und die
Sorge vor islamistischen
Parallelgesellschaften rechts und
nachdem man den Leuten jahrelang
eingehämmert hat dass alles vernünftige
Recht sei ja dann wundert man sich wenn
am Ende eine tatsächlich rechte Partei
eine Partei die Rechtsextremisten und
Nazis in ihren Reihen hat wenn die am
Ende aus so einer Debatte als Sieger
hervorgeht jetzt bei über 20% steht und
im Osten auf die absolute Mehrheit hofft
ja das ist doch nicht erstaunlich aber
es ist nicht das Ergebnis einer
besonders genialen Politik in der AFD
zentrale sondern es ist das Ergebnis der
falschen Politik im Berliner
Regierungsbezirk das muss man doch immer
wieder ganz deutlich
sagen und Frederik Frederik hat es
vorhin schon angesprochen jetzt gehen
also die ampelpolitiker selbst auf die
Straße und demonstrieren heldenhaft
gegen die ihrer eigenen Politik was ist
das für eine Heuchelei und
Scheinheiligkeit und man
muss man muss ganz klar sagen wenn Sie
die AFD wirklich Schwächen wollen ja
bittte schön da müssen sie nicht
demonstrieren da müssen sie endlich mal
ihre miserable Politik verändern sie
haben es doch in der Hand dann machen
sie es doch endlich mal so kann es doch
nicht weitergehen wie es jetzt läuft
und
ja ja natürlich ja natürlich beteiligen
sich auch viele viele Menschen an den
Demonstrationen weil sie ehrlich Angst
haben vor dem erstärken der AFD und sie
haben auch recht damit diese Angst habe
ich auch und ich glaube wir alle hier
die wir hier im Saal sitzen aber man
muss natürlich auch sagen wenn die AFD
wirklich Schwächen will der sollte auch
für politische Forderungen demonstrieren
er sollte auch z.B für einen höheren
Mindestlohn von wenigstens 14 €
demonstrieren weil der überfällig ist in
unserem Land er sollte für bessere
Renten demonstrieren für ein
Rentensystem wie in Österreich wo die
Durchschnittsrente ja tatsächlich bei
2000 € liegt Liebe richarder lang das
könnten wir hier haben da müssen Sie
sich nur mal Österreich das abgucken was
man dafür machen
muss und wer die AFD Schwächen will ja
er sollte auch für bezahlbare Energie
demonstrieren und gegen
wirtschaftsanktionen die nicht Russland
sondern die deutsche Wirtschaft
ruinieren er sollte demonstrieren für
ein mietendeckel und für Krankenhäuser
ohne Renditedruck er sollte
demonstrieren für Frieden für ein Ende
der Hochrüstung und am besten gleich für
Neuwahlen und ein Ende der unsäglichen
Ampel das alles fordert das BSW dafür
sind wir angetreten und dafür bräuchten
wir eigentlich
Massendemonstrationen denn wir dürfen
natürlich auch nicht vergessen auch wenn
die Ampel sich ihren Titel als dümmste
Regierung Europas jeden Tag aufs Neue
verdient weil sie unser Land in die
Krise und schlimmstenfalls sogar in
einen Krieg führt es geht um mehr als um
die Ablösung einer unfähigen Regierung
ein Friedrich märz im Kanzleramt der die
Rente noch weiter kürzen und
taurusraketen an die Ukraine liefern
will damit selenski demnächst mit
deutschen Waffen sogar Moskau angreifen
kann ein solcher Friedrich märz im
Kanzleramt wäre ganz sicher nicht das
kleinere
Übel
und
viele und viele Fehlentwicklungen denn
folgen wir heute spüren die haben ja
auch lange begonnen bevor das Trio
Infernale aus habg berborg und Lindner
unter einem sprachlosen Kanzler mit
lediertem Erinnerungsvermögen die
Geschäfte in Deutschland übernommen hat
das geht doch viel viel weiter zurück ja
es läuft nicht gut in unserem Land das
spüren die Menschen und Veränderung
beginnt auch damit dass die wichtigen
Fragen endlich einmal wieder ins Zentrum
der Aufmerksamkeit Rücken auch dafür
haben wir uns gegründet denn die Politik
und auch das debattenklima in unserem
Land sind roh geworden voller Verachtung
gegenüber denen die ganz unten stehen
und da sind sich wieder alle von der
Ampel bis zur AFD erschreckend
einig natürlich verstehe ich dass
diejenigen die jeden Morgen aufstehen
und hart arbeiten oder auch diejenigen
die für ihren Handwerksbetrieb ihr
Kaffee oder Ihre Bäckerei Händeringen
Personal suchen und keines finden dass
sie empört sind wenn andere sich im
Modell Bürgergeld plus Schwarzarbeit
eingerichtet haben das ist ein Problem
aber ein Problem haben wir auch wenn in
einem Land in dem die einzige noch
richtig schnell wachsende Branche die
Tafeln sind die mittlerweile über 2
Millionen Bedürftige versorgen wenn in
einem solchen Land nur noch über
Sozialmissbrauch und nicht mehr über
Armut geredet wird das ist doch ein
wirklich gravierendes
Problem nicht mehr geredet wird über den
61-Jährigen gerüstebauer der sich seine
Knochen kaputt gearbeitet hat und
einfach in seinem Job nicht mehr
arbeiten kann und dann gnadenlos nach
zwei Jahren Arbeitslosigkeit in die
Armut stürzt wenn nicht mehr geredet
wird über die alleinerziehende Mutter
die schon deshalb kein Jobangebot
annehmen kann weil die Politik bis heute
es nicht geschafft hat flächendecken für
ganztagskbl
zu sorgen und wir alle kennen ja die
Debatte wir alle kennen die Debatte über
die angeblich mangelnde Bereitschaft
jüngerer sich anzustrengen und die
Debatte über mehr Druck der da nötig
wäre aber vielleicht sollten wir auch
mal über Motivation reden die
Bundesrepublik ist eins mit dem Slogan
Wohlstand für alle gestartet jeder der
sich anstrengt sollte Aufstiegschancen
und die Aussicht auf ein gutes Leben
haben diese
Aufstiegschancen die gibt es doch fast
gar nicht mehr wer arm geboren ist der
bleibt fast immer Arm das ist die
Realität und dann wundert man sich wenn
junge Menschen die schon in ihrer
Kindheit immer nur verzichten mussten
die in maroden runtergekommenen Schulen
lernen mussten und die ein
Bildungssystem erlebt haben das noch
nicht mal in der Lage war ihnen halbwegs
korrek
Lesen Schreiben und Rechnen beizubringen
wenn diese jungen Menschen mit wenig
oder gar keiner Motivation ins Leben
starten ja das ist doch gar nicht
verwunderlich das liegt doch in dieser
Ausgangslage begründet und deswegen muss
man diese Ausgangslage verändern und
verbessern und auch dafür treten wir
an und was gar nicht geht was gar nicht
geht wenn dann verwöhnte Jungpolitiker
kommen die trotz besserer staatschancen
es oft auch nicht geschafft haben
wenigstens einen soliden Abschluss zu
machen und die jetzt schon
wieder und die jetzt schon wieder und
das finde ich besonders perfide das Geld
für die Qualifizierung und Weiterbildung
von Arbeitslosen kürzen wenn diese jung
Politiker uns dann den Wert von Fleiß
und Anstrengung erklären also das ist
doch wirklich ein Hohn auch gegenüber
den Betroffenen aber auch gegenüber uns
allen
dieselben dieselben Politiker übrigens
die sich als hochmoralische Gutmenschen
inszenieren die angeblich mit jedem im
Käfig gehaltenen Huhn und mit jeder
Kröte am Straßenrand leiden aber die ist
wenn es darauf ankommt die nicht davor
zurückschrecken frierenden Familien
schon wieder die Heizkosten zu erhöhen
oder den schon seit der coronazeit
strauchelnden gastwrd in die Pleite zu
stürzen das ist doch die Doppelmoral die
wir überall erleben und das geht so
nicht weiter
Politiker Politiker den es sowas von
egal ist wenn auf dem Land kein Bus mehr
fährt oder auch noch die letzte
Arztpraxis schließt aber die sich dann
hochmoralisch über alte weiße Männer
mckieren mit überholten Autos und
überholten
Ernährungsgewohnheiten das ist doch die
Diskrepanz zwischen dem aufgeblasenen
Moralismus dieser angeblichen
fortschrittskoalition und einer in der
Realität zutiefst amoralischen und
reaktionären Politik das treibt die
Leute um und das treibt sie den falschen
in die Arme das woll wir dringend
verändern und ja wir brauchen
Anstrengungen für eine
umweltverträgliche und klimaneutrale
Wirtschaft aber wir brauchen durchdachte
Lösungen und deswegen freue ich mich
auch dass wir so viel Kompetenz in
unseren rein haben auch bei dieser Frage
wir brauchen durchdachte Lösungen und
nicht eine Regierung die Milliarden
dafür investiert von dem relativ
umweltfreundlichen und klimafreundlichen
Pipeline Gas auf das extrem Klima und
umweltfeindliche freckingas umzusteigen
dass dann noch mit Schiffen über die
halbe Welt transportiert wird und die
gleichzeitig es für eine gute Idee hält
russisches Öl in Zukunft möglichst CO2
intensiv und teuer über Indien zu
importieren weil wir ja die guten sind
was ist das für eine verrückte Politik
das ist keine Klimapolitik das ist das
Gegenteil
eine Regierung die mit höheren CO2
preisen ihre Haushaltslöcher stopft und
gleichzeitig alles dafür tut dass die
barodebahn bloß keine gute und irgendwie
akzeptable Alternative wird eine
Regierung die zuschaut wie
Zukunftstechnologien die wir für die
klimawänd dringend brauchen wie die aus
unserem Land ab wandern währen sie
gleichzeitig den Aktionären eines
amerikanischen
halbleiterkonzerns der seine
innovativste Zeit längst hinter sich hat
10 Milliarden in den Rachen wirft wer
soll so eine Regierung noch irgendetwas
glauben und ja wir müssen wieder reden
wir müssen wieder reden über
gesellschaftliche Ungleichheit weil das
tut keiner über uns über die Enteignung
der fleißigen seit di Jahren sinken die
Kaufkraft der Löhne in Deutschland und
in vielen Branchen sinkt sie schon
wesentlich länger es gibt immer mehr
Berufe die früher einen bescheidenen
Wohlstand ermöglicht haben und in denen
die Einkommen heute so sind dass man mit
ihnen nie die Chance auf ein halbwegs
gutes Leben hat auf ein Mindestmaß an
sozialer Sicherheit auf eine solide
Familienplanung oder gar auf ein eigenes
Häuschen oder eine eigene Wohnung und
das muss sich doch wieder ändern in
unserem Land und wir müssen reden über
eine gespaltene Wirtschaft wo der
Mittelstand immer mehr unter Druck gerät
aber gleichzeitig auch das gehört ja
dazu die 40 größten Unternehmen in
Deutschland in diesem Jahr mitten in der
Krise mehr Dividenden ausschütten als je
zuvor das ist doch völlig absurd eine
solche
Entwicklung und
deshalb deshalb fordern wir deshalb
fordern wir schärfere kartellgesetze
auch gegen die Macht der Datenkraken aus
Übersee und den Abbau der ganzen
aberwitzigen Vorschriften und Auflagen
die eine ständig wachsende
beraterindustrie nähren und in den
kleinen und mittleren Betrieben völlig
sinnlos Kapazitäten binden auch das muss
ich ändern und wir müssen darüber reden
dass es kein Zufall ist dass der Mix aus
Steuersenkungen und Steuererhöhungen den
die Ampel den Bürgern in diesem Jahr zu
Beginn des Jahres offeriert hat dass der
wieder mal die ärmeren und die untere
Mitte massiv belastet während die die
richtig viel verdienen am Ende sogar
noch mehr Geld in Ihrem Geldbeutel haben
es müsste doch gerade umgekehrt sein
dafür setzen wir uns
ein
ja ich denke wir müssen wirklich auch
noch einmal nachdenken und auch darüber
reden öffentlich auch in unserem Land
wie wir unser gesellschaftliches
Miteinander und in unsere Wirtschaft
gestalten wollen Märkte und Wettbewerb
die sind ein gutes Instrument um
Unternehmen zur Innovation Effizienz und
Kundenorientierung anzuhalten aber das
gilt nur da wo Wettbewerb wirklich fair
funktioniert wo einzelen Unternehmen so
groß sind dass sie Zulieferern und
Kunden ihre Preise diktieren können da
iiert es eben nicht oder da wo es
natürliche Monopole gibt wie bei den
Stromenergie und auch bei den bei den
Kommunikationsnetzen bei den gasnetzen
da funktioniert es nicht und wo es um
existentielle Bedürfnisse geht wie
wohnen Gesundheit oder Bildung da
setzten Kommerz und Renditedenken doch
völlig falsche Anreize und das sehen wir
am krassesten in unserem
Gesundheitssystem wir haben das zweit
teuerste Gesundheitswesen der Welt und
trotzdem wartet ein Kassenpatient Monate
auf einen Facharzttermin während es kein
anderes europäisches Land gibt wo so
viele Menschen an der Hüfte und am Knie
operiert werden das ist aber nicht so
weil wir ein Volk von hüftlahmen sind
sondern das ist so weil wir den
Krankenhäusern eingetrimmt haben nicht
zuerst zu fragen was braucht der Kranke
sondern was bringt das meiste Geld ein
Gesundheitssystem was so funktioniert
ist krank liebe Freundin und
Freunde und wollen
wir wollen wir wirklich in einer
Gesellschaft leben wo sich alles nur
noch darum dreht aus Geld mehr Geld zu
machen in der wenigen enorme Macht
eingeräumt wird sich zu len aller
anderen zu bereichern in der der
ehrliche immer häufiger derum ist hat
der Mensch nicht etwas Besseres verdient
und ja auch Krieg Krieg ist für die die
über Kriege entscheiden anders als für
die die unter ihren Schrecken leiden vor
allem ein Geschäft da geht es um
Rohstoffe da geht es um einflussphären
under geht es immer auch um
Waffenverkäufe und ja auch hier sind wir
ja angeblich die guten wenn unsere
Außenministerin mit erhobenem
Zeigefinger durch die Welt reist und mal
eben beiläufig vielleicht auch Russland
den Krieg erklärt dann tut sie das ja
immer im Namen einer Werte geleiteten
feministischen
Außenpolitik so wie einst am Hindukusch
wird ja heute in der Ukraine unsere
Freiheit verteidigt und für unsere
Freiheit sollen die Ukrainer weiter
leiden und sterben und wir liefern Ihnen
die Waffen bis zum Sieg an den nur
leider selbst die ukrainischen Generäle
nicht mehr glauben ich finde das ist
eine so
unverantwortliche
menschenverachtende Politik dieser Krieg
muss beendet werden und war ganz schnell
auf dem Verhandlungsweg und das wäre
möglich wenn man es wirklich
wollte und ganz nebenbei also das in dem
Land das da heute angeblich so tapfer
unsere Freiheit und unsere Werte
verteidigt dass in diesem Land ein NAZ
Kollaborateur wie steepan bandera dass
Milizen am Holocaust beteiligt waren der
für die Morde an tausenden Juden Russen
und Polen verantwortlich ist dass in
diesem Land ein solcher Mann als
Nationalheld verteidigt verehrt wird
nachdem Straßen und Plätze benannt
werden ich finde es schon seltsam dass
diese wirkliche rechtsoffenheit unsere
grünen Moralapostel überhaupt nicht
stört auch das zeigt die Doppelmoral und
Heuchelei ihrer
Politik aber
offenbar offenbar werden unsere Werte ja
inzwischen sogar in Saudi Arabien
verteidigt immerhin will unsere
feministische
außenpolitikerin jetzt die diesem Regime
das Frauen zu Tode steinigt das
Oppositionelle köpft und in dem auch mal
eben ein kritischer Journalist zersägt
wird Iris Raketen und Eurofighter
liefern klar die Raketen tragen immerhin
den weiblichen Namen Iris also so viel
Feminismus muss im Hause bärburg
offenbar
sein
na und wenn dann in den
rüstungsverträgen vielleicht sogar noch
gegendert wird dann ist die grüne Welt
offenbar wieder in Ordnung aber unsere
Welt ist nicht in Ordnung und deswegen
sagen wir Nein zu Krieg und Nein zu
Waffenexporten in Kriegsgebiete das muss
gestoppt
werden
und ich
denke ich denke schon um diesen Wahnsinn
zu stoppen dass das kriegstüchtige
Deutschland in einer weltvoller kriege
jetzt auch militärisch wieder ganz vorn
mitmischen will schon und das zu stoppen
war es so wichtig dass wir uns auf den
Weg gemacht haben und dass wir uns
weiter auf den Weg machen und dass ihr
alle dabei seid weil auch das ist unsere
Aufgabe dass diese Kriegspolitik aufhört
und das ist ein ein ganz wichtiger Punkt
für unsere neue Partei wo wir weiter uns
engagieren werden liebe Freundinnen und
Freunde liebe Freundinnen und Freunde
wir haben Großes vor für unser Land und
für die Menschen die große Erwartungen
in uns setzen wir sind es ihnen schuldig
unsere Sache gut zu machen danke schön
[Applaus]
die Stimmung auf dem vorläufigen
Höhepunkt beim ersten
Bundesparteitag des Bündnis Sarah
Wagenknecht nach der Rede von Sarah
Wagenknecht 31 Minuten und jetzt wird es
hier die eine und andere Minute Applaus
natürlich noch geben natürlich stehend
wie für viele ihrer Vorrednerinnen und
Vorredner auch wenn die Vorredner hier
eindeutig in der Mehrheit waren ja lass
uns fleglich miteinander umgehen hat sie
in Richtung ihrer neuen Partei gesagt
lasst uns eine Partei des Miteinanders
werden wir sind keine linke 2.0 als sei
sie an den Debatten innerhalb der linken
Partei nie beteiligt gewesen und auch an
den Streitigkeiten die es da gegeben hat
was den pfleglichen Umgang angeht ist
sie mit den anderen Parteien etwas
weniger pfleglich hier vorgegangen hat
die ampelregierung die dümmste Regierung
Europas genannt hat von einem Trio in
Finale gesprochen von dem
Parteivorsitzenden dem Bundeskanzler
eben noch mit einbezogen
hat die anderen PolitikerInnen auch die
anderen Parteien als unfähig arrogant
und im agieren unsäglich genannt das
wollen wir hier nicht unterschlagen hat
hier natürlich auch prächtig gegen die
Medien ausgeteilt
wir senden trotzdem weiter hier noch
eine ganze Weile und sie hat sich wieder
für Frieden und Abrüstung stark gemacht
Krieg sei immer ein Geschäft sagt sie
und es bedürfe eines Neins zu Krieg und
Waffenexporten das kann ich Ihnen alles
ganz entspannt sagen weil der stehende
Applaus hier weiterhin anfängt anhält
ich vermute nur dass wir ein Satz heute
hier im Laufe dieses Tages im
Zusammenhang mit Krieg Frieden und
Abrüstung nicht zu hören bekommen werden
und das wird der Satz sein wir fordern
Russland auf den Krieg gegen die Ukraine
zu beenden dieser Satz wird hier heute
sicherlich nicht vorkommen nach all den
Rednerinnen und Rednern die ich bislang
hier gehört habe